there are a few topics that are
considered off limits and my family's
Thanksgiving table and one of them is
taxes or more specifically the American
tax system virtually everyone has a
strong opinion about it it's unfair it
doesn't go far enough
it's too complicated cable news and
social media are filled with passionate
debates about it but how many people
actually know how our current tax system
works if your eyes glaze over when you
hear phrases like progressive taxation
and marginal brackets you're not alone
even some of our lawmakers seem to have
a shaky grip on the concept but if you
hope to have a say in a system that
impacts your wallet every day you should
understand how and why it ended up this
way
[Music]
let's start with something all of us can
agree on the US tax code is complicated
really complicated it's one of the most
complicated systems in the world taking
the average citizen 13 hours to file
each year
compare that to say Japan where it's
closer to 15 minutes and one reason we
have such a confusing system is because
our income is taxed at different rates
depending on how much we earn for nearly
a hundred years our country had no
income tax the first one was levied in
1861 during the Civil War at a flat 3%
tax on income over $800 the next year in
1862 the first progressive tax bracket
appeared with the three percent rate and
a five percent rate for any income
earned over ten thousand dollars then in
1872 the income tax was repealed because
get this the government no longer needed
the money can you even imagine then in
1913 with a sixteenth amendment
progressive taxes made a permanent
comeback it gave the federal government
the free rein to tax workers income in
every state so what is a progressive tax
well you can think of tax systems coming
in one of three main flavors regressive
proportional or progressive a regressive
tax impacts lower paid workers more
severely paying sales tax on groceries
or clothing will end up being a higher
portion of a low earners paycheck than a
high earner a worker earning twenty
thousand dollars a year who pays $1,000
in sales tax will be partying with five
percent of his income another making a
hundred thousand dollars paying that
same tax for the same goods will only be
charged 1% of her income for the same
thing a simpler solution would be a
proportional tax where simply put
everybody pays the same percentage of
their income no matter how much they
make nine states currently impose a
proportional flat state income tax that
means no matter how much you make your
tax rate stays the same for example five
percent of every
finally there's the progressive tax a
system that has a heavier impact on high
earners lower earners may end up paying
little or nothing with only the
wealthiest people paying the highest tax
rates how does this actually work
through a series of different tax levels
or marginal tax brackets buckle up it's
about to get exciting let's say you're a
single person making 60 grand a year a
quick look at the IRS tax brackets will
tell you that you fall into the twenty
two percent bracket do you have to give
the government a twenty two percent of
your income Oh a common misconception is
that entering a higher tax bracket means
your whole income is taxed at the higher
rate so how much were you actually paid
after taking your available deductions
you're left with forty-seven thousand
eight hundred dollars in taxable income
as of 2019 we have seven marginal tax
brackets between ten and thirty seven
percent each bracket along the way
applies to one specific chunk of your
income not the whole thing bracket one
is for your first nine thousand five
hundred and twenty five dollars and it
gets taxed at 10% next stop is bracket
two this applies to twenty nine thousand
one hundred and seventy five dollars and
is taxed at a rate of 12 percent last
stop is bracket three where your
remaining income at ninety one hundred
dollars will be taxed at twenty two
percent even though you're in the twenty
two percent tax bracket your effective
tax rate is only about ten percent
thanks to the marginal rates in our
progressive tax system so a single filer
with a taxable income of five hundred
thousand and one dollar may be in the
highest tax bracket of thirty seven
percent but only one dollar is taxed at
that rate the effective rate will be
much lower
this system is definitely more
complicated than a flat tax but is it
fair simply put no a progressive tax
system by definition is unfair it allows
lower earners to pay very little tax
more than 44 percent of Americans paid
no federal income taxes and the more
money you make the less of it you'll
keep opponents of progressive taxation
tend to be higher earners arguing that
the system punishes wealthy people and
actively discourages making a higher
income they claim that a flat tax would
be simpler easier and more fair
supporters of a progressive tax however
point to the real world human impact on
struggling families and low wage earners
the argue if people have a greater
ability to pay then they should pay more
and a progressive tax system they claim
can counteract the regressive nature of
sales taxes easing the impact of taxes
on your rent or groceries while hitting
you harder in your ability to take
vacations or buy luxury goods and while
nobody loves paying taxes the average US
taxpayer actually pays less than almost
any other developed nation compared to
say Belgium we get off pretty easy their
lowest tax bracket is 25 percent and the
highest is 50 percent for anything over
thirty eight thousand eighty euros do
you feel our progressive tax system
encourages laziness does it discourage
people from earning more money or is it
giving a leg up to people with lower
salaries whatever your opinion now that
you understand the mechanics of marginal
brackets and progressive taxation you'll
be in a much better place to argue about
it over your next Thanksgiving dinner or
in the comments section and that's our
two cents thanks to our patrons for
keeping two cents financially healthy
click the link in the description if you
would like to support us on patreon I'm
sure you have an opinion about our
current tax system go ahead and put it
in the comments
you could share it with your elected
representatives
you
[Music]